it has been quite a while since we did
any caption contest and i know people
like to get in on these and you know i
was kind of missing sassy who we lost
last month and i thought this would be a
good picture to use
for remembering her and seeing what
people had to say that would be funny or
witty or anything like that and
producing a new caption contest
video so just for anybody who doesn't
know at this point what we're talking
about i throw up
a picture in my community tab in youtube
and then people
give their comments on it and the top 10
or in this case we'll also do a bonus
one
get into the video and some people you
know are they're a little hit and miss
some people are
a little bit more on point than others
some write very very long comments that
are not particularly suitable but we've
got a good mix of comments ahead so with
no further ado
here is the very first one
this is a great one philosophers when
they hear someone say begs the question
when they mean raises the question you
know and it's showing sassy getting
upset you know she's not actually
hissing she's actually yawning but i
think that's that's a good one and there
are a lot of people who
mix those two things up it seems to be
more and more common these days
let's look at the next one now this is
referencing something like hp lovecraft
sassy had faced many eldritch horrors
during her lifetime
but none of them was as horrific and
unavoidable as the blanket of the deep
as the cosmic horror prepared to devour
the cat she could only scream in horror
knowing what was going to happen and you
know she's cuddling under the covers
this is quite a interpretation of what's
going on but funny nonetheless
here's another really good one this
reference is heavy metal of course
sassy's thought bubble okay sadler this
is my best rob halford hitting his sixth
octave in victim of changes as anybody
who knows their medal
lore uh is well aware of rob halford has
what we often call an operatic range and
he is a powerful singer from
very down in the base and all the way up
into
the
uh high end and victim of changes is one
of those songs that has that i mean
painkiller would be another great
example but this is quite good
here is one that's a good pun
it's tough to make puns work well you
know
but this one is pretty good uh hey sassy
who's your favorite author
fangs kofkat and this works on a number
of different levels obviously you know
franz kafka playing around with the name
things she's got some significant fangs
as cats get older and sassy was probably
18 when i took this picture you know
their fangs get longer and longer and
stick out of their mouth and then cough
cat you know a pretty nice
little
thing there
doing you know playing around with the
the word
all right so here is the first of two
that reference mice and we don't
actually have mice you know we live on
the eighth and ninth floor
of a
old building that's been converted into
lofts and so we barely get bugs up here
and and you know not even mice but sassy
used to play along with her sister
teensy with mice and other things when
she caught them back when he lived in
kingston so feeling lazy but optimistic
sassy impersonates a mouse hole because
she's like halfway under the covers and
then the next one
here we've got like a nietzsche
reference going on
sassy sees the mouse and says if i don't
kill you i'll make you stronger right so
sayasi is herself part of the process of
what do we want to call it you know
intensification of mouses or something
like that
then we get now we're getting into
things that are more philosophical and
so here's another one caption
what do you mean epicurus wasn't a cat
and
you know somebody might quibble and say
well you know epicureans weren't about
animal pleasures well actually you know
they could be cool with that they think
that every animal upon birth seeks out
pleasure and the greatest of pleasure is
what being untroubled and resting and
what's sassy doing in this picture she's
like waking up from a nap and maybe
going to another nap so that's pretty on
point
here's another good one knowing that
sleep is the highest good sassy prepares
to cultivate you daimonawia
so you know playing off the the word
eudaimonia and inserting a meow in there
and you know this is actually kind of an
interesting one you could say what is
the highest good for
not human beings but what is eudaimonia
for a cat or for other animals and sleep
is certainly
a major part of it for for cats isn't it
now we're starting to get into stuff
that's a little bit more
abstract you've got to have a bit of a
bit more background knowledge to know
what they're referencing
the absolute yawn is appearing as the
negation of sleep being a waking
activity yet is the formal
representation of sleep as such now that
could be hegel that could be
schopenhauer that could be kant it's
certainly within the realm of
german idealism talking about the
absolute and negation being part of it
and formal representation
and you know the joke works i think if
you if you know the background here's
another one obviously a reference to
kierkegaard's sickness on to death the
very first
and famous introductory
parts of it the cat is a relation with
which relates itself to sleep or it is
that in the relation that the relation
relates itself to its sleep the cat is
not the relation but that the relation
relates itself to its sleep playing off
the fact that you know we are relations
to the relation of ourselves to things
and there's this complexity
there
finally we have a honorable mention and
here it is
mondays right
if you don't know what the reference is
for that it's to garfield and we used to
make fun of sassy from time to time when
she would sit back and you know on on
her her back legs and look kind of like
garfield with a fat belly sticking out
and her paws sticking down you know when
she'd be cleaning herself
a lot of cats do that sort of thing and
garfield was known for disliking mondays
although of course garfield didn't do a
lick of work and frankly
sassy didn't have any assigned work
either although she did her functions as
a cat quite well so thanks for coming
down you know memory lane with me a bit
and seeing what people have to say
i'll do more caption contests and
i gotta you know find some good images
to use for that so you know you'll see
them come up on the community tab in my
youtube channel you do have to turn down
your notifications if you want to be
notified of when they're going to arise
otherwise you can obsessively check it
if you like
that seems kind of a waste of time to me
but we've got plenty of other ones that
we've done
previously and we'll do more of these in
the months and years to come
you